hey folks welcome to the dark horse
podcast live stream i now know for sure
it's episode 115. i can surmise just by
staring at it that 115 isn't going to be
prime right i mean not even close really
and we're coming to you 20 hours late
sorry about that um
and let me before i forget top of the
hour uh we're not going to be here next
week we may sneak in a an extra episode
somewhere but we will not be here next
weekend
yep but i should say before we get any
further congratulations we have
accomplished something substantial
we are
well no we have half accomplished
something substantial we are more than
halfway through winter
this is true which is wild i mean you
know we've gone around the corner it's
uh warming up the days are getting
longer it's uh it's quite something yeah
this is this is the time um in the
season where the the photo period is
palpably changing daily like the days
are getting longer and here in the
pacific northwest we've had a couple of
just completely glorious spring-like
days which does
does a lot to help with with the mood
even when the rest of the world seems
very dark and of course what is
happening um
in ottawa also does a lot to help with
the mood we continue to hear we'll be
talking
um a little bit a little bit about this
today but really um
just continue to encourage people we've
been hearing
we've been hearing from people there um
i will continue to post about it on on
my sub stack on natural selections and
um
what is
what is happening
um in canada with the freedom convoy
truckers for freedom it's going by a lot
of different names i think you know
history has not yet decided what it will
go down as but um the legacy media's
take on it
uh
seems to be being disbelieved by more
and more people as so far as i can tell
it is demoralizing to see the the
absurdities that they are spouting
continue to be spouted
but
uh there are now many many people who
are live streaming from ottawa i've
mentioned viva fry here before and i
think he's the biggest and he's just
extraordinary at what he does there are
a lot of people doing it also from the
ambassador bridge
and
going there and watching just the
footage on the ground of what people are
experiencing and who these people are
is
is
it's beyond heartwarming that's just
that's such a triviality this is
um humanity in action this is democracy
in action but that's too small this is
sort of the best of what humanity can
bring yes it's great and it is also
marvelous that the authoritarians appear
not to have considered that there would
come a day when people would start
waking up to their [ __ ] and so they
keep doubling down and
you know uh trudeau
bless his heart
really fascistic sounding stuff and you
can just kind of read it there you can
say huh gee i wonder if these are the
good guys they don't really sound like
the good guys and the fact that you know
we have armed police descending on the
bridge um
you know it's all the ambassador bridge
between uh windsor ontario and detroit
michigan yeah it's quite clear who the
um
who the good guys are in this case
and uh anyway it's also amazing that
this is an international
movement this rebellion against the
authoritarian instincts of
um our various
federal governments is it's it's
important
yes indeed uh just keep talking for a
minute right all right sorry i'm going
to keep talking about uh
well
oh boy i'm not going to be able to find
it um someone uh in my my twitter feed i
don't like to go do that very often but
um posted an excellent response with
regard to sort of you know
who are the good guys here and i could
summarize it but i was hoping to
to find it and i'm not finding it so
well here's the thing
it just so happens that this week the
universe has delivered us a completely
unambiguous signal about who the good
guys aren't and we are going to go there
so to the extent that people may be a
little bit hazy on this concept by the
end of this broadcast you will no longer
be hazy because they have effectively
announced we are not the good guys
indeed
um
all right so just logistics before we
before we continue on on content for
today's show uh we are streaming as as
usual on both youtube and odyssey and
odyssey is where the chat is if you are
here live with us
you can ask questions for the second
hour which we'll be doing after we're
done here now at
darkhorsesubmissions.com
we never get to all the questions but we
encourage you to ask them when we get to
as many as we can
you may
consider joining us at our patreons we
had bret had
your conversations for your patreons
last weekend and they were as usual
spectacular yeah spectacular amazing how
many really interesting people show up
and uh i know the purpose of these
conversations is not for me to learn
stuff but i do every time
it's like a really good
classroom environment there it is like
right right there right and that and
that indeed is one of the distinctions
between
what um so many people are craving and
what i believe uh we were doing both in
the classrooms and are trying to do here
and what the legacy institutions are
informing us that we absolutely need to
sit down and be responsive to uh both
the the you know public health officials
wielding their scientific credentials
and uh the educational system saying sit
down shut up receive the wisdom and
then unto you shall be you know educated
or public health or whatever it is and
of course that's not that's not the way
you get educated that's not the way
science works that's not the way a
democracy democracy should work and
that's not how humans
uh wander around their worlds trying to
make it better for other people and
themselves
by simply taking information not
questioning it and accepting it and and
having it add to what amounts to an
ideology as opposed to a working model
of how the universe works and how they
should behave so
um yeah what you describe as your
patreon conversations
uh is you know it's funny that you
you know you have to almost apologize so
that you felt compelled to say well you
know it's not it's not for me because
these are people showing up and and yeah
in this case paying some money just like
with college education right you're
showing up you're paying some money um
therefore it's not supposed to be for
the professors but for god's sake if the
professors aren't learning something
from the interaction then it's probably
not much of an education is it
yeah that's absolutely right and
although it was not my plan i
would like to revisit
this
question about how education should work
in light of mdm and i realize most of
you don't know what mdm is but you're
going to know i don't think i do right
you don't do all right right you're
going to be amazed but i think if we
take the mdm taxonomy and i'm not saying
msm mainstream media we all got that one
are you going to remember this or should
i be taking notes uh you don't have to
take nuts we'll take pencil nuts you
take mental nuts uh done okay okay so
when we return to the mdm taxonomy we
can map it on to the very high quality
model of education that we have just
discussed and you know take it out for a
spin all right we'll we'll be spinning
it yep um
we have as usual if you're interested in
dark horse merchandise or direwolves or
epic tabbies or
digital book burnings uh
that stuff is available at
store.darpourspodcast.org
as i mentioned already natural selection
is my substack which is at
naturalselections.website.com
i haven't had nearly as much this week
as last week but this week i did post
some of the remarkable portraits uh that
a canadian photographer by the name of
dana ponte boy he and i have been in a
lot of conversation i'm not actually
sure i'm pronouncing his name correctly
i hope i am dan um
i posted some of the remarkable
portraits that he took uh on the second
saturday of the trekkers convoy of the
truckers for freedom uh protests in um
in ottawa which i've now begun to hear
people calling in um an occupation in a
in a good way like this is you know this
we're here we are here and we're going
to stay here until the mandates go away
and that's and that is part of what
we'll be coming back to after we do our
ads and such here well i feel like
occupation actually
is a little bit like i think the term
woke
right some of us were not sure what to
call the woke revolution back when
people typically called it uh social
justice warriors right because social
justice warriors is pejorative and if
you want to just simply say this thing
fails on its merits i don't need to you
know i don't need to label it badly in
order to reveal how broken it is the
point is woke is a term that's actually
viewed positively inside the movement
and those of us on the outside can use
that term and say look this is nonsense
it's not what woke used to mean and i
think
occupation you know i've seen a lot of
battling around it doesn't strike me as
negative because of course you know
i will speak for myself i was part of
the occupy movement which became an
absurdity but it started out as a
legitimate
complaint about the tarp program and the
financial collapse of 2008 and what it
revealed about corruption and the point
was occupation was a method when we
didn't have a method to get the
attention of the government and say
actually this is unacceptable you can't
do this to us right too big to fail is
an excuse to bail out people who caused
this and it's falling on our backs
occupation was the method and
i must say i am um
excited to see that occupation has been
um
upgraded by
clearly
clearly working-class people
um who have a legitimate gripe with the
federal government which has obviously
captured the imagination of many many
millions of people not just in canada
but across the globe so and this is part
of where we'll be going yep shortly um
an invitation
to web developers out there we are
looking for one someone who is
um you know hopefully beyond competent
uh who is both creative and technically
skilled and who can potentially build
some sites for us
such that we can then
do
updates and maintenance on them
ourselves or or have someone else do
that on our behalf
anything you want to add to that before
i and so we encourage you to send
your information along with links to
some of your work to darkhorsemoderator
gmail.com
do you want to add anything
sorry the reason we delayed yesterday's
podcast is i have had a
gluten reaction a cough which i think
owes to a big hit of gluten that i
accidentally ingested
um anyway it's much better than it was
but i will try not to cough through the
broadcast
but yes i would say in looking for this
web developer we're looking for somebody
who
has skills enough to take what we're
looking for and figure out how to
problem solve around these things so
there are obviously lots of people who
can put up a web page but it needs to be
a web page that we can modify that we
can uh make specific requests and and uh
um that you have the skill to to bring
it into reality rather than to force
what we're looking for into uh some mode
that you have experience building and
we're looking for a few so this could be
an ongoing
uh relationship that was beneficial to
to all hopefully all right um
so then without further ado we will
bring you our three sponsors for the
week as usual we are grateful for them
they help provide
um
a serious financial buffer for us in an
era when um there is de-platforming and
demonetizing going on all over the place
so we are
we are grateful for their support of us
and their enthusiasm for what we're
doing
okay our first
our first sponsor for the week first of
three is seoul a sustainable orthopedic
footwear company seoul is one of two
footwear sponsors that we have and we
love them both they are quite different
from one another while both being
focused on creating shoes that help feet
get and stay healthy and people become
more mobile
our other sponsor vivobarefoot
specifically aims to give you the sense
of being barefoot in your shoes hence
the name soul sole with both their shoes
and their footbeds bring structure back
with intention
which may well be a better move on
specifically hyper novel environments
like the concrete and asphalt that so
many of us are mostly working on working
on walking on
soul aims with its footwear to return
our feet to health and the shoes by sol
are beautiful
so let's create a foot bed that is
affordable customizable and improves
people's everyday foot comfort
furthermore they've created their own
recycling program re-cork to collect and
upcycle wine corks to make its products
millions of customers rave about the
product and two-thirds of seoul
customers have two or more pairs of
footbeds
our two boys are wearing these shoes so
much of the time now they take some
getting used to the structure under the
arch is unusual
but once you get used to them they
provide great support for feet they
really do i i'm wearing a pair too
and again they look great so
sole shoes look terrific but if you're
just looking for footbeds to make shoes
you already own be healthier for your
feet try the footbeds
also they make a flip-flop that isn't a
flip-flop so if you're a fan of a shoe
like i am that you can quickly slip on
to step outside if it's wet or dirty but
don't want the downsides of a flip-flop
being slippery having to grip with your
toes to stay in it which is not good for
your feet then this is the shoe for you
seoul has an amazing offer for first
time customers a 50 off through
yoursold.com darkhorse so you can try
seoul for yourself that's
y-o-u-r-s-o-l-e dot com slash darkhorse
they are so confident that you will love
them they also offer a 90-day money-back
guarantee it's very hard to go wrong
with that offer and this offer is
applicable to all items on the sole
store be it footbeds or
footwear all right all right number two
our second sponsor is ned no not ned the
dude ned is a cbd company that stands
out in a highly saturated cbd market
ned was started by two friends who
discovered that their hyper-modern lives
were leaving them feeling empty
bewildered and disconnected something
about something about this way of life
they say on their website just wasn't
working so they started ned you can buy
cbd products in nearly every coffee shop
grocery store but ned's blends stand out
their de-stress blend in particular
really impressed us ned's distress blend
is a one-to-one formula of cbd and cbg
made from the world's purest full
spectrum hemp and also features
botanical infusion
oh goodness uh ashwagandha
ashwagandha i got it of course i think i
got it yeah uh ashwagandha cardamom
cinnamon cbt is known as the mother of
all cannabinoids because of how
effective it is at combating anxiety and
stress by inhibiting the reuptake of
gaba gaba the neurotransmitter
responsible for stress regulation i will
say that reading about this does induce
stress
sounds like what you need is now wow
too late all right many of the cbd
companies out there source their hemp
from industrial farms in china just like
with low quality alcohol however low
quality cbd can have undesired effect
ned is usda certified organic all of
ned's full spectrum hemp oil is
extracted from usda certified organic
hemp plants grown by an independent
farmer named jonathan
in
payonea colorado
also ned shares a third shares third
party lab reports and information about
who forms their products and their
extraction process on their site so you
can read about it
these products are science-backed
nature-based solutions that offer an
alternative to prescription and
over-the-counter drugs they are chock
full of premium cbd in a full spectrum
of active cannabinoids terpenes
flavonoids and trichomes ned's full
spectrum hemp oil nourishes the body's
systems to offer functional support for
stress sleep inflammation and balance if
you'd like to give ned a try dark horse
listeners get 15 percent off net net
products with the code darkhorse
visit
helloned.com
darkhorse to get access that's
h-e-l-l-o-n-e-d
dot com slash dark horse to get 15
percent off thank you ned for sponsoring
the show and offering our listeners a
natural remedy for some of life's most
common health issues
our third sponsor for today is relief
band a product that can help with nausea
first though a little bit about nausea
as we've talked about before under
ancient circumstances and some modern
ones nausea was generally a useful
signal that something is off you had
eaten something you shouldn't have or
were near something emanating a bad
smell itself a signal that you should
not get near it we talk about this
actually a bit in hunter gatherer's
guide in modernity we still need to
track our bodily sensitivities we should
not always choose to simply erase
discomfort like nausea whenever we feel
it that said some of modernity creates
nausea that does no good at all travel
sickness for instance can be agonizing a
relief would be lovely enter relief band
relief band is an anti-nausea wristband
that has been clinically proven to
relieve and prevent nausea associated
with motion sickness anxiety migraines
chemotherapy and more reliefment is 100
drug-free and can be used for as long as
you need it developed over 20 years ago
it is the only over-the-counter wearable
device that has been used in hospitals
and oncology clinics to treat nausea and
vomiting there are zero side effects and
now there's relief band sport as well
which is waterproof features
interchangeable bands and has extended
battery life we asked a friend to try it
out
here is her testimonial
quote i used to have nausea on a near
daily basis from both anxiety and the
need to take regular medication relief
band relieves my nausea in less than
three minutes without the side effects i
was experiencing from anti-nausea meds
it has entirely changed my life for the
better
end quote so if you've got nausea from
anxiety or car or seasickness or
something else that you cannot otherwise
disable consider relief band relief band
makes a great gift for any time of year
right now they've got an exclusive offer
just for darkhorse listeners go to
reliefband.com and use promo code
darkhorse to receive 20 off plus free
shipping and a no questions asked 30 day
money back guarantee that's
reliefband.com
and use our promo code darkhorse for 20
off plus free shipping
that's our sponsors for the day you know
i never used to have car sickness but as
i get older i find that i do i'm just
totally sick of cars
yeah i don't think i don't think this
will help with that
i think it's i think that's a shame i
think that's different that's different
yeah i think not driving could maybe you
could put one of the bands around the
car yeah that's interesting
yeah yeah
i think i heard zach groaning with
appreciation for your comment
maybe appreciation
maybe exasperation could be good yeah
one of the you just don't know when
you've got a when you've got an amazing
teenage producer yes yeah
yeah
okay
here we are um
as always these days there are
practically an infinite number of places
we could go
and so we will miss many of the things
even that we had decided we really
wanted to cover no doubt
but i was thinking maybe we start by
talking about
what you and i are both seeing um but
have somewhat different perspectives on
although i don't think that they are
incompatible perspectives i think we are
just kind of
filing them differently
with regard to
the the
the creation
explicit really creation of tears in
society so
um
i've been
i've been alarmed frankly i mean and
part of this is just obvious
much of the reason that there is so much
pushback against vaccine mandates by the
vax to unvaxxed alike
is that many people are seeing
accurately that this is created a
society in which some people have access
to all of the things that we have always
had access to and some of us do not and
that this creates
um this this creates a an opening
and indeed an opening that many in the
media are eagerly pushing as many people
through as they will take
to uh suggest that those of us who are
therefore excluded by virtue of mandates
are are dirty our carriers of disease
are less worthy are perhaps not quite up
to the challenge of being full
participants in democracy even
and uh
for those of you who would suggest
that's hyperbole just wait till we get
to what brett has to bring to you but
um
i will say that the thing that is
um
and it's not the most alarming thing
because what you're going to talk about
is the most alarming thing but the the
two-tiered society is that that is
happening all around us that uh you know
the city that we live in portland oregon
does not have
uh mandates in place uh you know
there are there are many restaurants
where we can still go
um but there are many that we can't
whereas in cities like new york new york
city and los angeles and seattle and
many others uh i am sure but those are
the places where i know people who are
there who are uh who are you know
good
honest people
who have accepted the vaccine mandates
without hardly looking at what it means
and so i personally have been encouraged
to come to these cities
and
just be there and you know enjoy the
fruits of
i don't know enjoy the cultural
offerings of the cities
and
the the people and this is many many
people i'm not pointing my finger at
anyone in particular but there are many
people at this point who um
have not even realized
that
i'm not invited
like they can invite me but having
gotten there i would not be able to do
any of the things that you would want to
do in a city the city is announcing that
you are not welcome right
and
that's the vaccine mandate side of it
the part that is so alarming to me is
how many people
even
people with
you know recent history in their
families
of having been through the introduction
of a two-tiered society in which people
became dirty and untouchable and
unmentionable and then
not there
can't see this for what it is
feel that it is at best
a minor inconvenience a fly buzzing
around that yes uh that's unfortunate
but
and it is this it is this
i don't know if it's an inability to
notice or an unwillingness to notice but
a not noticing of the thing that is
happening in front of us
which is part of why
so many of us are
utterly thrilled that the truckers and
their supporters
and
their allies in ottawa
and it coats and at the ambassador
bridge in canada are holding the line
are there on behalf of so many of us
saying no to mandates
no to mandates yeah it's um
it's a beautiful thing for many reasons
for one thing the hypocrisy couldn't be
made more obvious by anybody other than
truckers right the truckers who were
heroes you know have now become villains
because they're standing up for
just simple rights yeah and the idea
that this thing will pivot on you and if
you are you know keeping civilization
afloat then they will hold you up as a
hero but then they won't even listen to
you right it's like what we do to
veterans yeah where we beckon them into
you know national service fighting on
our behalf and then we pretend that
they're not sick with what they're sick
with and we abandon them when it comes
to taking care of them once they get
home
and
that hypocrisy you know
i detest it as i know you do
but it is very revealing to the extent
that it allows us to see who we're
dealing with they weren't serious about
these being heroes they are heroes but
but the point is that was cynical and
this is cynical and
it is
important that we recognize
who these folks are it reveals and later
on i do want to talk about what it means
what the elite and the aspirational to
the elite
think
working class means and what they think
it looks like and
and yeah this has been said often um
including by us
but the cynicism reveals the disdain
it reveals the disdain for the people
who
are
think that they're writing history
think that they're in charge
because they have because they work in
the quote unquote knowledge sector
knowledge sector
my god the misinformation sector perhaps
uh and
there are
there are a tremendous number of people
and i dare say it's
if it's a minority it's a giant minority
and i'm not certain it's a minority
who
have their eyes wide open
and who don't have the financial power
but are actually doing the work of
society
and
at the point that they say
enough
it is shocking to those who are actually
contributing little beyond words and
most of those words aren't honest
to see them scramble and to see them
tell lies
well and to see them reveal how little
they understand about the world yeah i
don't know if you caught
um i don't remember her name but uh
harvard professor was shouting this week
on twitter about how the obvious
solution to the bridge problem was to
slash their tires and drain their gas
tanks and then remove the trucks and
he's revealed okay complete failure to
understand what would be necessary to
remove the trucks in the first place um
among other things the high pressure in
those tires would make that a
particularly dangerous activity okay but
i guess i want to say you know both how
perfect it is that it's a harvard
professor but
i fear that this
you know
all of our understanding that you know
the ivory tower really is a tower out of
which people like to peer and uh you
know what made us different as
professors was that we insisted on not
doing that
and it made us unfathomable to many of
our peers um but also actually education
educating students and approachable and
interacting with um the people with whom
um we were supposedly you know in a
power relationship with right
so i would say it's not just
the people at harvard right it's it's
you know it's not just with regard to
the if we're just limiting this to the
academics how you know how confused most
the people in academia are
um it's it's not just the elite
institutions uh it's it's everywhere
this thing is everywhere this belief in
i have this terminal degree just which
you know just means you know i could
mean a lot of things
i'm afraid you've got a case of terminal
degree it's a decrease that will cause
you to be so stupid it could end your
life yeah um but uh yeah in academia
when we say that we just mean it's the
last degree that you can that is offered
in that field so uh you know in general
it's a phd but it could be an md or
or a jd as well law degree
or i mean i guess an mfa maybe a
terminal degree as well masters of fine
arts because there's no phd in finance
anyway i digress
those people who have gone as far as
they can in school and gotten their
terminal degree the last degree that
they can possibly get um often just run
to more school because it's the only
thing they know and because school
wasn't about educating or knowledge of
the world
that means that what they then feed to
the next generation is is even more
limited like this partially explains
like narrowing and narrowing narrowing
and less and less relevant and um
actually mind-expanding and eye-opening
version of higher ed that we're seeing
that people are not just being catalyzed
into ever more specialized fields um but
they they look around go like well i
don't understand what's going on out
there the wind wow nature is complex and
you know the actual interactions with
people how about i just categorize them
as i don't know deplorables or nazis or
whatever it is and go back to my
little room where i can say that all you
need to do is slash the trekker's tires
and we'll solve this problem well it's
hilarious this was not hilarious and it
is this this was obvious to us when we
were
working academics right you could walk
into a faculty meeting and you could ask
yourself the question how many people in
this room actually know something that
would be good for students if they were
to pick it up right and you know
it was not a high enough percentage to
make sense of a a college or university
you know that i i had i adopted a bar
for how what you should what you should
have in order to be qualified to teach
college students yes
and it was a really low bar
it was two things
you should
it's kind of three things maybe maybe
it's a slightly higher bar than i
thought you should know something real
that you can communicate
and i thought of those as one thing know
something real that you can communicate
and fundamentally believe
in the humanity of your students
and the number of academics i've met who
fail on one or all of those fronts is
astounding
utterly astounding and even if you think
oh well they do they know something real
they they're kind of dynamic as a
lecturer well get them behind closed
doors where you can't the students can't
hear them and the kind of talk that goes
on is
it's horrifying yeah and
you know what people can feel this
just like people who are actually
working class actually doing work that
needs to be done can feel the disdain
dripping off the legacy media and the
academics and the elites in government
and public health so too can students in
a classroom feel when their professors
have no respect for them at all and they
don't show that the students know better
than to not show it but it's a it's a
big theatrical game
i also adopted a bar
that i would go to after faculty
meetings in order to try to
shake it off you know
go a long you didn't but that's you
could have well yeah um
but yes it's a
it's a fascinating it's a fascinating
puzzle but i think it also you know if
you go back to your original point about
look i don't really want to go to new
york new york is broadcasting i am not
welcome
uh for phony reasons of my being a
hazard to somebody which i am not right
and of course this does unavoidably
allude to you know juden frey and uh all
sorts of um uh historical circumstances
that we now understand clearly in
retrospect um but
i also think it is it is worth
understanding how we got here yeah right
and how we got here means how you and i
got here
and it also means how those people who
don't understand that they're inviting
you to a city that is broadcast and you
are not welcome don't see it right yeah
because what happened to us as our
longtime uh watchers and listeners will
know
is that at the beginning
of the uh the vaccine campaign you and i
were alarmed by the fact that the public
health authorities were saying these
things are safe and effective and we
knew there is no way they could know
they are safe it might turn out that
they were harmless but it's not safe
because they couldn't say anything about
the long-term impacts nobody on earth
could and so to tell us there's no risk
here when we can tell there's no way you
could know there's no risk was alarming
out of the starting gates we know you're
lying to us maybe the lie has no effects
but the fact that you are doing that
right away tells us we can't trust what
you say right and people will remember
the example that if you walk into a room
and there's a gun on the table and you
put it to your head and you pull the
trigger and it goes click was it harmful
no was that a safe activity absolutely
not right right and so the point is
those two things are distinct we all
know what they mean if we think
carefully about it and you and i were
alarmed and that caused us to delay what
we thought we were going to do which was
get vaccinated but the point is let's
give this some time and see if anything
emerges that suggests this isn't a good
idea
and then those things did emerge now
many people
understandably
did what one does in light of a vaccine
that they are told has passed safety
tests is useful in fending off a disease
that we know is dangerous and they got
vaccinated quickly well i think more to
the point they were told
that if you do this and enough of your
countrymen do this everything goes back
to normal you get your lives back and
that was
clearly never going to happen um and i
don't know if it if it actually would
have happened had these been the safe
and effective treatments that we were
told they were and
presumably
hopefully no one knew how not safe and
not effective they were uh at the time
we were being told that
but um
it was not it was not just
oh the public health authorities tell me
to do this therefore i'm doing it it
wasn't it wasn't that kind of
acquiescence it was also
a desperate need to return to people's
lives and people bought it people people
believed
because they needed to believe because
they were done being in lockdown and
being kept from each other and being
scared of a thing they couldn't see they
had they were convinced they convinced
themselves
that this was the panacea this was going
to be the thing
they believed because it was
inconceivable that they would be lied to
in this way many thought they were being
lied to as a matter of noble lies but it
was inconceivable that somebody was
going to misrepresent these things at
this level but
i think i think you and i are saying two
different things i think they're both
true but uh
what i'm saying
is not about
the lie whether or not you whatever it
was
it is about sorry
about why people wanted to believe yeah
and i mean i think this is actually so
you know we're going to get to what you
want to talk about
here with regards to the other kind of
tier being created in society uh and
you know the place where you and i and
again i don't think it's that we aren't
seeing things um
i don't think it's not that we're not
seeing things eye to eyes that i think
we have a fundamentally sort of like
different first interest in the story
um and you know we're obviously does you
know what does the science say but i
keep trying to figure out why are people
behaving the way they are right and and
um and the why are people behaving the
way they are
from from talking to people
i can see how desperate they were to get
their lives back
and overlay that with the narrative of
well this has to be true they couldn't
possibly be lying to me at that at that
level but that's an overlay that's a
cover story and what they were actually
driven by i feel
certain many people was just giving my
[ __ ] life back right of course just
give it back to me okay and you know and
this this language and i think i was
taken to task at one point
here not by you but by the audience for
say for using that kind of language just
like you know give me my rights and you
know give me my life back
no
i'm
i'm i'm taking
what is mine
you you did not have the right to take
this from me these are inalienable
rights right that's why our constitution
is special is it spells that out these
are your rights and here are the onerous
requirements that the government has to
reach in order to take them away from
you there's a reason it is structured
that way and
amazing that um canada albeit much more
recently has something very similar in
its constitutional charter right now
the point i wanted to make about our
friends who i think
are having what is apparently a natural
reaction where they are failing to
notice that we their friends are not
being welcomed by the city they live in
because of some uh absurd story about us
being a hazard to people like we all
know enough about these vaccines that
they fail to
to prevent people from contracting this
disease they don't reduce viral load
they don't prevent you from passing it
on so the point is on what basis are you
actually not welcoming me but
but my point is
there is a process which i am certain
that the people engaged in manipulating
us understand in which if you have
complied even accidentally you complied
months ago because you thought you were
going to get your life back for doing so
and now you are in the state of having
complied
that it is very hard to see those who
are excluded by
this thing right and so it is actually
exactly parallel to the idea
that when there is a structural bias in
society
if you are on the winning end of it you
may not like the idea that there's a
bias you may not have put it there you
may not defend it but the point is you
are much less exercised about it than if
you were on the losing side of it right
and so i believe that this is where we
are the people have complied because it
was because the inertia pointed in that
direction and now they are uh
surprisingly deaf
to the fact that you know american
cities
differ in how welcome people are
at restaurants based on whether or not
they accepted an experimental medical
treatment that we now know doesn't work
to prevent contracting disease like
did i just say that sentence right right
yeah
okay so you wanted to go
somewhere beyond this yes uh so just
i mean i can set up like we we had a
disagreement we went um
we went on a nice bike ride on friday
um just as you were about to get hit by
the gluten bomb um and on the way out
there and in the car ride we was like we
did not start from our house as we
normally would but we went out to rails
to trails
and
um i was talking about this two-tiered
society and you said well it's really
three-tiered and i end up disagreeing
with you that this i i feel like these
are two categorization schemes that can
be mapped onto one another but not a
single categorization scheme um but in
that light why don't you introduce well
i think you know i was alarmed because
you were spreading mal information mal
informational information
is that like malocclusion or somewhat
different well you know it's interesting
i don't know i know that it's a thing um
i was alerted to its being a thing this
week by the federal government um so
anyway male information male information
that's what they're talking about now
well sure okay um but we're going to
need to look it up because are we okay
yeah it's probably nothing it's probably
just a synonym for you know miss and
disinformation
but
it's good to check
you want me to do that well yeah why
don't you um go to this
i think uh heather's gonna do it here
you wanna is it this one was the other
one
uh is it the screen you want
okay so there's a lot of quiet now okay
on air while you're looking at this i
don't i don't know what we're doing we
are going to
this pair do you want to put up my
screen or not sure yes okay
apparently so we need to go back i don't
know what just happened okay
i don't know what's happening can you
read this paragraph which one the one
that starts wild
the united states united states
so so this is a department of homeland
security advisory that they put out i
believe on february 7th yep alerting us
to a hazard to the homeland that we
should all be aware of okay i think we
should start at paragraph three
paragraph three reads the united states
remains in a heightened threat
environment fueled by several factors
including an online environment filled
with false or misleading narratives and
conspiracy theories and other forms of
miss dis and mal information whoa mdm
introduced and or amplified by foreign
and domestic threat actors these threat
actors seek to exacerbate societal
friction to sow discord and undermine
public trust in government institutions
to encourage unrest which could
potentially inspire acts of violence
mass casualty attacks and other acts of
targeted violence conducted by loan
offenders and small groups acting in
furtherance of ideological beliefs and
or personal grievances pose an ongoing
threat to the nation
okay now notice that they this is the
first time i'm seeing this this is
terrorism that they are talking about
and their point is that there are
foreign actors oh yes and domestic
actors who are spreading
miss
dis and mal information what the hell is
mal information
well we'll get there okay and um
these threat actors terrorists
are
in a position to create unrest
by sowing the mystics and mal
information online which could
potentially inspire
acts of violence
right so that's an amazing amazing
that's a lot of weak links it's a lot of
weak links but you know maybe they're
going to rescue it with mal information
whatever that is maybe mal information
is the concept we have been waiting for
in order to separate the terrorists from
the rest of us
let's see okay so here we go zach
we're back on this page at the
the issuance on february 7th of the
national terrorism advisory system
bulletin now they are very helpfully
hot linked missed information that's
where i am now scroll down and they will
give you a taxonomy so actually go down
a little more what is mdm
okay so misinformation
yeah would you read the definition of
misinformation misinformation is false
but not created or shared with the
intention of causing harm so wait some
of these terrorists
are
guilty of spreading misinformation but
it's not intentionally misinformation
they're just kind of you know wrong
doesn't this make
both wolensky and fouchy terrorists no
no no no because they are part of the
federal government that is deploying
everybody knows that they're not terror
come on anthony fauci is a terrorist oh
there's an exclusionary clause
it's not really a clause but it's kind
of a come on right it's a comm on it no
they're not right so
basically what this does is it defines
as actually we have no idea about their
intentions
i have no idea no i think their
intentions are good
well then that's it's mere
misinformation that they have right yes
but but by the definition so
the science changes we keep on being
told now haven't been led down this
idiotic primrose path that followed the
science and a bunch of us in the
beginning we're like that's not how
science works hello hello hello and now
they're saying well the science changes
so at the point that the science changes
how like what's the what's the period
during which you're allowed to still be
believing the past science
before you convert to the future science
before you are a purveyor of
misinformation and therefore a terrorist
you my dear are missing the glory of mal
information oh i'm not there yet you're
not there yet you have not understood
that although it sounds preposterous
that these people would be defining as
terrorism the
being mistaken and not realizing it and
saying stuff out loud that didn't turn
out to be true that's misinformation
sure sure sure right let's go to the the
disinfectant yeah yeah disinformation is
deliberately created to mislead harm or
manipulate a person social group
organization or
country okay so let me give you an
example of uh disinformation
so let's say
that the uh tide corporation
says that you mean like the you mean
like procter and gamble
i don't know who makes tide but you're
talking about the laundry detergent well
sure okay okay let's say for example i
don't actually know
that they were to to say
no laundry detergent gets clothes
brighter
than tied right now the fact is
they might say that and it might be
true
but it's meant to mislead you it's meant
for you to hear
that actually tide gets closed brighter
than other detergents when really what
it says is maybe there's no difference
between these detergents they all kind
of do the job right so all advertising i
think all advertising is now terrorism
which you know i've always kind of felt
that way about advertising
but um anyway but you know here's the
problem the rubber really meets the road
the whole taxonomy kind of you know so
you've got people who are
uh unintentionally wrong about stuff and
so terrorist here's the thing yeah
i i'm just gonna say it
i have been
unintentionally wrong about stuff what
various points in my life i feel like i
should have known this i feel like you
did know and sometimes you're the person
who points it out but
in any case that puts me squarely in the
crosshairs of this but you know uh
frankly uh here's the thing though yeah
sometimes those shoes are on the other
feet
it hurts like hell i'm also in the
crosshairs
shoes on the other feet in the
crosshairs it's a mixed metaphor but
we're going with it
um it was your crosshairs metaphor right
but they're my shoes
i have also sometimes been wrong
unintentionally and you have to point it
out okay but here's the therefore i'm
also in the crosshairs here's what i'm
imagining many in our audience
will also have it who do terrorists
could be so silly
that's the thing they're sneaky sneaky
people and uh you know humor we're gonna
get to humor actually but but here's the
point okay um many in our audience
will have been wrong at various
occasions right and do better do better
yeah right be wrong i mean not even less
because you don't want to really be a
better tennis while you're at it right
okay and then
you know disinformation
that does seem to cover not only
advertising but a huge fraction of
comedy
you know very poor chip
uh-oh what don't i know
it's been a long time since we were
recording that's true um
no but
you know a charm offensive a make
yourself look better than you i mean
this is what
you know all
all non-human organisms engage in
disinformation right crypsis is
disinformation right
oh
god you're right yep so it's even
non-human terrorists yeah oh for sure
yeah right um
yep okay but the glory of this really
has to it has to be rescued by male
information a term that i think nobody
until this memo had ever heard of right
so it's gotta be pretty good
it's so good let's see mal information
is based on fact but used out of context
to mislead harm or
manipulate you got it should i read the
last three lines or should we just stick
with that i think we should uh that's
the definition of the uh
of the male information so this is great
because malin i'm thinking about uh
and indeed i was i was just reminded of
i went back and looked at my fact
checkers aren't scientists piece which
was my very first post on natural
selections
and i walked through
you i think it was you and robert malone
being fact-checked in politifact which
is facebook's fact-checking arm just put
that
right like
scientists don't belong to anyone
they're not supposed to if they're doing
science but fact checkers can belong to
people
okay um politifact fact checked you and
i believe it was this claim that got a
pants on fire rating uh that the spike
protein is toxic or cytotoxic
and uh meanwhile research out of scripps
which scripts his own pr
department
posited
said that
spike protein is toxic yeah the spike
protein is toxic it's toxic but that
saying that based on fact so for a while
i know it's not no it's not no it's not
and
apparently okay it is but that's mal
information because how dare you talk
about that here right because dare you
talk about it because
what i was trying to do
was raise people's awareness that the
public health authority was misleading
them about safety and the fact that i
was accurate is no defense because i'm
still a terrorist because it doesn't
matter that it's based in fact even true
stuff is mal information that's the
beauty of this definition is that the
fact that it's true is no defense yeah
right how dare you say it yeah it's
okay so misinformation is false
false but accidentally accidentally
false disinformation is is is bad
but it includes crips and advertising
and such uh in courtship a lot of it uh
and but male information
just includes
ah it is mal information
is in even more than miss or
disinformation in the eye of the
beholder that's the distinction right
mal information is in the eye of the
beholder and when the eye when the
beholder is the government
and the government gets to behold you
and make a claim about whether or not
you're a terrorist
and
this is it's this is all it needs then
anyone all of you anyone at any time can
be declared to be engaging in terrorism
anyone at any time and that's just the
beginning of the fun oh good um but
let's go back and map uh
this on to for example
the teaching environment okay let's do
it so
for example let me just point out that i
in teaching
used all three of these techniques i was
sometimes wrong now when i was wrong
somebody would sometimes raise a
question that would reveal that i was
wrong and i would then correct what i
had done but i was still guilty of
information terrorism in my teaching let
me just say that another way that
happened for both of us was
um
we'd say something and no one would call
us out because it wasn't no one knew and
then we'd go back to our lives and like
wait um
okay no actually that wasn't right and
then we'd return
of our own
of our own volition and say that thing
that i said was wrong correct your model
yep okay
that's that's that would have been
misinformation misinformation yeah right
in an educational environment right
shame now i was actually voted
misinformation in high school as you'll
recall back when you were a woman
uh no i don't know i think they were
making fun of me but um
but in any case uh
another in educational environment in
which misinformation was relevant but i
think two s's um
disinformation so i used to use
disinformation as a teaching tool
sometimes i would um you would lead them
down a path that you knew to be wrong i
would lead them down a path that i knew
to be wrong and i would do so
while hinting with my eyebrows or
whatever
that this was a good direction to go so
that they would pick up steam and then
at the point they got someplace i would
start asking them questions like
paradoxes that were raised by all of the
stuff that they just signed on to and
the point is
stop
listening to authority stop reading the
social cues pay attention to what
do use your logic
use your analytical and creative
faculties in order to assess what is
right rather than paying attention to
the social cues of the authority in
front of the room
eyebrows though he may have
some will argue eyebrow but
never mind um
but anyway it was a very useful
technique one does it with humor one
does it with generosity in their heart
nobody ends up upset about it because it
actually ends up educating them and then
mal information of course who doesn't
use mal information in their teaching
because basically mal information uh are
facts and when you use facts like let's
say the uh
brett's flood scientific calamity right
you teach about how science is a
fallible process and how sometimes your
heretics are actually right and so
anyway all three of these are yeah so
you know to
again mal information the definition out
of the terrorism are with the united
states government which i'm sure is not
how they like to be referred but uh i
think that's basically terroristic no
i'm going to call it the terrorism arm
okay um
male information is based on fact but
used out of context to mislead harm or
manipulate and um you know a
two there's a lot hidden in two like how
do you know the intentions of of the
person um but mislead
ought to be perhaps a minor crime harm
we don't want people using um facts to
harm
others
although obviously it's not as simple as
all of that but manipulate
to manipulate
what were you trying to do i was trying
to manipulate them because they're my
students and i was trying to make them
more educated so that they could see
this sort of thing this sort of tactic
when it is done by people like you
in the future and can be better immune
to it thank you very much how do you
become immune to this sort of thing
except by having been having fallen prey
to it in the environment that is
actually safe an actually safe
environment in which oh my god i got
duped by my professor who's got great
eyebrows how did that happen like well
now you know and now you're gonna have
to do it a number of times because um
you know we all too often when you when
we've been duped once we've been fooled
once by the public health authorities or
the professor or whatever it is
we take that as the instantiating thing
like that is that is the generalized
thing right and just and i'm reminded of
um this is going to seem like a
non-sequitur but i'm reminded of being
in costa rica um
the second time for us but with a bunch
of grad students and our professor
and we said something and it was the
first time for all the other grad
students but we we had traveled through
central america on our own
a few years earlier and we said
something about well when we were here
before the weather was
and uh professor vandermeer who we're
there with said yeah the first time you
come to a place in the tropics
that's the weather system that you think
is
that year is normal every year
thereafter is not exactly yeah that
that's that's the thing that you then
imagine is normal and there is not a
normal year afterwards and you're always
trying to track what happened like well
what happened was you happened to arrive
at that moment and had you arrived at
any other moment you would think that
was normal
so that you know that's
um we need
we need ourselves to be to expose
ourselves to our own failings and and
failed thinking multiple times because
just doing it once
means that that's the only thing that we
look for and this is actually this is
it's like people looking for jack-booted
thugs for evidence of tyranny you're
right i mean that's and that's the
problem with with history as well we go
oh well i know i know what tyranny looks
like
i've
i've seen the documentaries
and
no a that's not what it looked like as
it showed up and also it will never look
exactly the same right you have to
familiarize yourself with multiple kinds
and by the way at the point that you've
got some number of people in society who
aren't allowed to participate and are
being slandered as dirty and evil and
not up to the job
that's tyranny coming that is what it is
right and basically what's protecting
them is that they have learned not to
goose step or put skulls on their
helmets this time right we're we're
watching take much tyranny but you know
if that sounds like an exaggeration
we'll get to the next part but um we're
going to give you links to this memo i
would encourage people to click around
this site we go down to the uh we want
sect to be showing yeah mdm resources
i got to say mdm just i you know i keep
on expecting the a at the end right
exactly now scroll down you've got a
list of mdm resources war on pineapple
yes war on pineapple is on there i did
not hack the site and put war on
pineapple there it's there of its own
accord
um
but there are other delightful things
okay on this list warren pine i know i
know but they do say tongue-in-cheek
this is the first time i've been here i
i'm just looking at a government site
that has border security cyber security
and disasters in the left menu and war
on pineapple and i really don't know
what just because these people
just because these people are just
because they're fascists doesn't mean
they don't know how to have fun
okay hold on go back to that list of
resources
okay there's a uh there's something
about quashing rumors start your own
rumor control page where the rumor
control page oh remember control page
startup guide sorry
oh so here you've got a nice handy
graphic in which they effectively oh
this one has a bolt mal information has
a bullhorn facts yes facts that's a
bullhorn broadcasting fact that is
nonetheless a terrorist threat but you
wanna it okay and the news is the
mystery good job not to point me to this
before we were on air what the news is
misinformation right wait
okay
anyway it's kind of glorious we don't
have time to go through all of this but
it you know it's the site that keeps on
giving this one has the creepy eyes the
creepy scroll down a little bit okay
there's another thing
oh
well a rumor control page is how you can
brown shirt your own site oh cool to
control
rumors which includes mal information
which are facts
right but presented out of context to
mislead harm or manipulate context right
i remember correctly
it is the test darling um all right go
over here to uh this uh
myth graphic do you want me to click
yeah would you describe it you don't
have to click okay it's all right there
um it is it is a um it's got myth uh
which is how do you communicate
effectively on a rumor control page
which is again your brown shirt site
just uh designed to quash mal
information which again are facts that
are presented out of context so as to uh
lead people to understand the corruption
of their federal authority who put out
this document yeah so what you do is you
use a um
a
defined class
a magnifying glass is the debunking
magnifying glass oh magic debunking
magnifying glass
it says debunk no it says debunk the
magnifying glass you asked me to
describe it but that's not how you're
going to use it
preemptively debunk or
there you go now
i haven't even said it for those
listening it says preemptively debunk or
prebunk yep prebunk yes your federal
authorities are now advocating on your
brownshirt website that you prebunk so
as to fend off facts that are being
distributed by other people
pre-bunk pre-bunk
okay so also preemptively pre-bunking
seems redundant
no it's it's pre-pre-bunking i think
look and if you don't do that the reason
that you would want to pre-bunk is
because you might have to rebunk right
yeah i need to rebunk because the
science can change well if somebody
debunks your bunk then you're going to
need to rebunk and it's much better to
pre-bunk in order to avoid that it's
that awkward i know that's what i like
to do
okay yeah so your question earlier yeah
about what happens when you're right and
you say the true thing and they say the
wrong thing and then later they have to
admit that they were wrong right right
what was the grace period the answer is
there is no grace period you're not
allowed to contradict them right even
with the facts right right because
that's uh
mal information uh that has apparently
not been effectively pre-bunked right
now among the things that our listeners
and viewers will find on the site which
i do encourage them to look through very
carefully because really it's one jaw
dropping revelation after another is how
blatantly unconstitutional this is this
is a clear violation of the first
amendment and it gets worse because not
only are they encouraging people to
brown shirt against facts
right which is uh clearly bad but they
are also they willingly acknowledge that
what they are doing is they are
partnering with um people in the private
sector you know tech platforms and the
like it's a private public partnership
it's a private it you know yeah it is
largely innovated by uh
iid with fauci
oh not innovative because they had
historical precedent because this of
course is the cinquano fashion not not
innovated but um
made mainstream
publicized with great glory associated
with it by fauci and then head of the
nih columns right
now
all of this glorious fascism has a
beautiful cherry on top does it which we
are not going to show do we like
fascistic cherries or do we not well we
like that they are revealing themselves
and while they are not going to goose
step or put skulls on their hats they
have published a couple of graphic
novels about these
terrorist misinformers
cherry with a nazi hat on now i think i
think that's perfect probably coming i
don't know but anyway do check out their
graphic novels um there's a graphic
novel i i've only looked at one of them
this graphic novel is about i think it's
about 5g conspiracy theorists but the
hero you want me to go back through
here's uh scroll down to the resources
wait here this or not yeah real fake
graphic novel what does that mean really
oh real fake is their first graphic
novel the other graphic novel though
bytes yeah bug bites exactly do you want
yeah actually you should just show it
you can show that so this again is mdm
not mdma resources uh in case you were
wondering
um yeah i'm not feeling warm or fuzzy at
all well show it um
we're still in the cyber security
infrastructure security agency
resilient series graphic novels graphic
novel real fake graphic novel bug bites
invites
click on it
uh just that
yeah there you go
yep
bug bites okay so here is bytes with a y
but bytes b y t
yeah just scroll through a little bit
disclaimer yeah so this is a graphic
novel now this uh attractive white woman
her father works for a communications
company and was viciously attacked by
terrorists and she
terrorists engaging in male information
was it well i don't know it's somehow
being distributed by the people who are
exercised about male information but if
you keep scrolling down you will see her
as the hero of the story see she puts on
her mask here
um bottom of the page there
right um and then anyway outside look at
her walking alone outside with her mask
right i know and uh
anyway there's a marvelous trailer for
this uh on youtube which you can click
to uh we're not going to do it here but
anyway this is hard to parse in in real
time but oh yeah those do look like
terrorists yeah they really do i mean
they are they blew [ __ ] up but um but
the point is but that's but that i mean
that's that's what it leads to that's
like
when you hear terrorists you think
people looking like that doing those
sorts of things and that just as i want
to talk about before we if we're done
here today um the image of what the
working class are is you know it's
factory workers
and you know our our pat little images
of who particular
who belongs to particular categories
is helping us be controlled
and is going to help
you know if if that's what we all live
in our mind oh you're not only showing
the screen but if you know um
bottle rocket hurling
what are those called the balaclava
balaclava wearing no no no the the
explosive
i don't know what explosive right it's
it's a it's oh
cocktail sorry
yes
so molotov cocktail throwing
terrorists is what we all have in our
heads about what terrorists look like
and then everyone frankly everyone has
just gotten slotted into at any moment
that we want to we call you a terrorist
but as soon as we do so then this is
what is going to be called up okay in
people's heads so let us
get to where the rubber really meets the
road here because everybody listening to
this is going to say yes okay this is
crazy the federal government is
declaring people even people who are
distributing facts out of what the
federal government decides are context
whatever that means right that those
people are terrorists so yes this is
very ominous stuff but come on nobody's
actually going to believe that
somebody's saying true things on the
internet as a terrorist so in the end as
awful as this is what does it matter and
here's the problem
um can you show the other
page i sent you okay so this is the aclu
scroll down to you want exactly showing
my screen uh scroll up let's get rid of
their fundraising thing okay that's okay
now you want sector yes
this is the aclu here's the problem
in 2012 actually in 2011
the omnibus ndaa national defense
authorization act which is a giant
ominous bill that we yearly use to
refund
a lot of things the military being
primary among them
had two provisions slotted into it this
was signed by obama on the last day of
the year 2011. yes and the last day of
the year 2011 is significant not because
it was a legally significant date
but it contained these two position
provisions 1021 and 1022.
the
provisions well let's start with the
signing
by so he happened to be in hawaii on
december 31st
and where his home was right it was very
very good reason for him to be in hawaii
however by signing in hawaii
late in the day
new year's eve on new year's eve that
ensured that the rest of the world would
have moved on to new year's eve
celebrations that's what not was not
paying attention at least the rest of
the us right
and arguably
these two provisions end the us
constitution now i know how preposterous
that sounds and i
agree that there are interpretations by
which that would not be the case but the
problem is what these provisions do if i
remember correctly him signing this is
part of why you could not bring yourself
to vote for him a second time it is
absolutely
sufficient reason right there and i will
tell you a little bit of the history so
these provisions allow indefinite
detention without charge or trial of any
person including american citizens
picked up anywhere on earth for
effectively engaging in terrorism or
supporting those who do
so my point since this moment
since the moment that this thing was
signed was
terrorism is a magic word when the
executive branch uses that term they are
declaring your rights null and void you
don't have a second amendment right if
the federal government has the right to
put a black bag over your head and haul
you off and not tell your family where
you've gone and not
there's no rid of habeas corpus they
don't have to charge you you don't get
the right to see the evidence against
you you don't have a right to privacy
all your rights you're a citizen no
you're a terrorist right and this is the
reason that you and i had a disagreement
in the car is because with them using
the term terrorism there are now three
tiers of citizens there are fully
compliant citizens who can go to
whatever restaurant they want
there are uncompliant citizens who have
resisted
let's say vaccines that they are
mandated to take and are now forbidden
to go certain places
and then there is a third category which
is terrorists and the problem is you
have now seen what the federal
government does with this definition so
i
as as you know and as i think i've even
made clear already here um
this is
by far worse
uh than
not being able to go in a restaurant
because you're not vaccinated
but it feels to me like it is
unnecessarily confusing and will
actually make it make it hard to make
the point to put these into a single
category you have i think there's two
categorization schemes here you have um
you know vaccinated versus unvaccinated
and then you also have um has been
declared or has not been declared a
terrorist and maybe you know maybe
that's not quite the right naming of the
categorization categorization scheme
over here and there is i think i said
that wrong but you know maybe you have
to flip that one over
there is a lot of overlap between those
two categorization schemes or at least a
lot of potential overlap
um between the of course you're still a
citizen and you're vaccinated groups in
the two categorization schemes and they
know you're not vaccinated and oh yeah
at any moment it might declare you a
terrorist group i think i think there is
likely to be
uh some considerable overlap there
but they're not
as as it is with the two different
categorization schemes they really are
complete categories there's not
muddiness between them you aren't
members of of
two things within a single
categorization scheme you either are or
you are not vaccinated and of course
there is some muddiness there you know
some some
places are now not letting you in if
you're not boosted so you know what does
fully vaccinated count for um that
definition will move um
but uh
the you know could you be
uh declared a terrorist well everyone
could be so everyone's in that could you
be given their definitions of malness
and disinformation
but
have you been is the category and are
you at risk of being is a squidgier
category here and i guess i would say
this
between the ndia of 2011
and uh and the new thing from february
7th from the
terrorism branch the government or
whatever it is um
we are in
trouble
we are wait we are we're in a lot of
trouble as as a country as a democracy
that
the fact that most people the vast
majority of people won't have any
awareness of either of these things ndaa
from end of 2011 yes from just over 10
years ago still most people don't have
any idea of it right
and
you could any random person on the
street could legitimately claim well i i
just honestly don't know about that
right and that is
that doesn't make it okay that doesn't
make it any less terrifying but they
could honestly declare and it could be
true and i think it is true for the vast
majority people they don't know whereas
that first tier that first
categorization of two tiers that i'm
describing the vaccinated versus the
unvaccinated
in most places in this country as far as
i know although i do i think that there
are places like florida and and texas
where there is where this is much less
true
at least in the
the blue cities and the coasts
you actually cannot be existing in
society and not know
that there are now two tears
if you have ever been asked to show your
papers and know they don't use that
language but if you have been asked to
just show your back square
then you know and you have no excuse and
the fact that you are pretending not to
know or pretending that it's not a big
deal that paves the way for this this
ndaa followed by the february 7th
declaration or whatever it was called
and that is far worse but what i'm
saying is the thing that everybody does
know that there is no excuse you can't
ask someone on the streets of new york
city or la or seattle or a whole bunch
of other cities did you know that there
you know that if you don't have you know
vaccine
evidence of vaccine you can't get into
restaurants of course they know because
they've shown their papers every time
they have gone in of course they know
well and so they are complicit i think
they don't have any right not to know
it's in front of them i think they know
if they are showing their passports
which they are well there's a question
about what no means and look i'm not
obviously i'm as troubled about this as
anyone but the question is how is the
magic trick done yes right and this is
falling but it's these it's these two
things and they're and they're distinct
strategies i believe
that's fine um but
to the extent that people are hearing
about the ndaa 2012 for the first time
here so why do we call it the ndaa 2012
because it was the 2012 bill in which
these were inserted
oh so he signed it on the last day of
2011 but it's it's the 2012 bill okay um
here's the thing you should check out
the new york times from the following
day all right the new york times has
complete pdf versions uh from january
1st 2012.
yes now many of us you're gonna have a
hard time finding it but um i've been
through it
with a fine tooth comb now if somebody
can find it in there great i'm all ears
but my claim is you can see the aclu
which used to be a civil rights
litigation organization it's now become
a woke monstrosity
but the aclu will
uh validate that at least the
interpretation i've given you is a
credible interpretation it's not just me
and the aclu saying that what you will
also be unlikely to know
is that chris hedges and noam chomsky
sued the obama administration over this
these two provisions
a federal court ruled that chris hedges
had standing to sue that he was in fact
in danger of being targeted because he
had interviewed members of al qaeda
and the way these provisions are written
that could plausibly put him in danger
of being indefinitely detained so let me
just since you had me show this site
before the aclu says
the breadth of the this is and this is
again from 2012 back when the aclu was
doing the honorable work that the aclu
was formed to do rather than be coming
though what did you call it the woke
monstrosity it has become now
the breadth of the ndaa's worldwide
detention authority violates the
constitution and international law
because it is not limited to people
captured in an actual armed conflict as
required by the laws of war and then
just next paragraph
although president obama issued a
signing statement saying he had quote
serious reservations about the ndaa's
detention provisions the statement only
applies to how his administration would
use them and would not affect how the
law is interpreted by subsequent
administrations yes and the provisions
parenthetical are inconsistent with
fundamental american values they are
inconsistent with absolutely fundamental
values that actually go way before the
u.s constitution right get rid of habeas
corpus for example right
so
among other things
what we know is that a federal court
ruled that this was a
a plausible interpretation enough that
they were willing to hear it right the
law was suspended as a result of that
and then a three-judge federal panel
reversed that and
put it back into force
now here's the problem an ordinary law
were it to be used against you there
would be a mechanism for dealing with it
right there would be a court and you
could argue
that this was unconstitutional
in this case what the f what the
executive branch has effectively done is
it has given itself the ability to
declare someone a terrorist
have that person disappear not explain
where they've gone until
the end of hostilities so presumably
that's the moment at which on a planet
of nearly eight billion people there are
no more terrorists it is an implausible
moment they have given themselves the
ability to detain somebody without
explaining where they went without
showing anybody evidence and so do you
say it's until hostilities cease the end
of hostilities in the hostilities the
end of hostilities which is obviously an
absurdity they've declared the entire
world of battlefield they've said
terrorism is the style of battle they
get to define who's a terrorist and uh
then
you can you will be returned at the end
of hostilities which couldn't possibly
ever happen because there will always be
terrorists i mean
there's no description of how the
coveted pandemic ends it's the same
thing with the war on drugs it's it's
all of these things we establish
something uh with which we then use to
grant ourselves special powers and there
is no uh termination
condition right so again this is the
most special of laws because it does
there's no check on it even if you say
that's impossible that any court would
listen to such a law the question is
well if you disappear and your family
doesn't know where you've gone
right because they've decided that
you're a terrorist and they can detain
you someplace and never tell anyone what
happened you're just a missing person
how do you get to a court and say the
federal government has violated you know
my right to see the evidence against me
you don't there's no court yeah um and
so anyway again you can say that's
preposterous your interpretation is
bizarre but the point is first of all a
federal court said that uh chris hedges
had standing to sue that he was in
danger of this happening to him
so it's that credible yeah right and um
i will also point out that when the
obama administration responded
their
bizarre response to this suit was not we
don't have those rights that's not what
it says their response was we already
had those rights
so in any case it does point out also
how much the disintegration of once
honorable and absolutely necessary
organizations like the aclu has also
paved the way for what we're living
through now right there were there were
you know plenty of people who disagreed
with particular things that the aclu may
have done but they were consistent
they defended
they defended everyone who was having
their rights trampled
and now what they're doing is shutting
you down if you think men can't become
women right that's that that seems to be
the you know the reigning issue of the
day for them well men can't become women
as mal information
i don't it's a fact
ah you see
but
i don't think it's male information in
this case because male information
requires out of context so is saying
anything without context inherently mal
information because it needs to be their
context all i said was men can't become
women what context right but that's my
that's what i just said um so mal
information requires that it be out of
context i believe well first of all the
um
opinion in this case of whether or not
there is or is not context coming as it
does from a misdis and malinformer
herself indeed is effectively null and
void because i mean look the reason that
you haven't yet been hauled off to be
indefinitely detained
without the right to see the evidence
against you is simply the good graces of
the federal government which you
apparently still exist in
indeed um
anyway look yeah it's a kafka trap right
and it's right there on this uh
department of homeland security yeah
website
they're not hiding it it's written in
garbage ease but you can sort your way
through it and the answer is look
this is actually the thing we were
warned about it just is right this is
the tyranny it's not ambiguous right
this is them declaring factual
information that might cause people to
be upset and not trust the federal
government as terrorism and then
declaring that they have rights when it
comes to terrorists that extend up to
everything right
sorry that's check and mate right they
just did it to us right you can't say
facts without them declaring you a
terrorist and if you're a terrorist they
can do anything they want to you have no
constitutional rights you know this
isn't tyranny how is that not tyranny
right
you could talk about the weather no
probably not no here's what you do if
you don't want to fall under their
definition of misdis and mal information
the mdm of it all if you want to avoid
that you take the thing that we used to
be told if you can't say anything nice
don't say anything at all and you just
do the last part of that you just don't
say anything else yeah could you please
shut up already and we're next time
we're not going to ask nicely that's
what it is that's what that's what we
are being told right it's a shot across
the bow now
do i expect to be disappeared i do not
because that would cause the problem
which is that it would reveal what
they're up to but you know there's a
reason that they are moving the chess
pieces around the board this way and we
of course will be the last to know what
that is and i guess just just to return
to what seems like a disagreement but i
don't think really is
i think these are two sets of strategic
moves that are happening in parallel one
of them is not noticed by almost anyone
because almost no one is paying
attention to the ndaa and the
terrorism declaration from february 7th
of this year
but the fact that
everyone who lives in
most of the highly populated areas of
the united states
has encountered either being asked to
show their papers or um knowing that
because they have no papers they cannot
go places knows damn well what is
happening and if they are not looking
that squarely uh in the face and going
this
this harkens bad things
then they need to start doing that you
need to at least recognize that this is
exactly that serious and no
what's happening in canada is not about
people saying you should not be allowed
to take a vaccine it is about vaccine
mandates it is the mandates and you know
obviously all of this conversation about
ndaa and such has been u.s specific but
uh you know as uh jordan peterson's
recent conversation with the honorable
brian peckford who i mentioned on last
week's live stream but didn't say a
whole lot about he is peckford is
bringing he's one of the he's the
uh
former first minister from newfoundland
who is the one remaining
uh living
member of the of the framer of the
constitutional charter from 1981 or 82
in canada
um is bringing a lawsuit against against
canada because
what is happening there is fundamentally
unconstitutional and i see no similar
thing happening here
but it it needs to and frankly what's
happening
with peckfruit in canada is uh
absolutely 100 supported and revealed to
be supported by many canadians by what
is happening in ottawa and also at kutz
and at the ambassador bridge okay and
for my part
i will say we have to return to william
binney's formulation here william binney
being an
nsa officer
who
became a whistleblower
and when interviewed
what he said
was holding his this is when um
would have been a decade ago okay um he
said we are this close to a turnkey
totalitarian state right and the key
insight here is turnkey right a
totalitarian state that doesn't feel
like a totalitarian state until they
turn the key and the point is the fact
that that state is being erected around
you is on the department of homeland
security's website right right down to
their propagandistic
graphic novels and their absurd
invitation to pre-bunk stuff right this
is the turnkey totalitarian state
putting up the last little pieces of the
structure that allows them look you've
got a set of definitions that no one who
has not taken a vow of silence could
possibly escape right you're going to be
guilty of misdis or mal information
whatever you do and that means that any
day they can decide your constitutional
rights are no longer rights at all which
means that your constitutional rights
are a privilege they've rendered these
things a privilege and that's what a
totalitarian state would do so um
have they turned the key will they turn
the key we don't know but we need to
understand that the danger of the
turnkey totalitarian state is not the
turning of the key the danger is the
erection of the thing which they've done
can we can we go back to what i was
talking about though sure with regard to
canada and and what is happening there
so i just i wanted to i was trying to
segue and now we're elegant pivot
yeah i didn't i i don't know how to do
this now because turnkey is state is
is where we just were and it's [ __ ]
necessary but i want to talk about
something else which is related but it's
really not in that tenor okay so what is
happening with peckford's lawsuit and
at the ambassador bridge and at kutz and
in ottawa is
critical in part because
uh it is it seems shocking to the legacy
media and the would-be elites the elites
and the would-be elites
um
because they can't imagine
that the lower classes would ever rise
up and this is this is the argument that
this is actually
effectively a class war and it does
remind me of occupy right it does in in
in many ways that this is effectively
the the people who
don't have the power to write the
scripts at the moment but who are
actually making the democracy run saying
finally [ __ ] this i am not putting up
with this anymore we have lost too much
we have lost human beings we have lost
loved ones we have lost economies we
have lost our jobs we have lost our
stores we've lost our businesses we've
lost our friends we have lost our agency
our ability to travel we have lost too
much we are done
and frankly the so-called knowledge
workers who have lost far less by and
large far less because they can afford
to have the people who are actually
doing the real physical work of the
world bring all their stuff in
and assume that the supply chains will
just keep functioning because it's i'm
sure there are people there doing that
fundamentally neither understand nor
respect the work that people who don't
look like them do okay
so i wanted to read
just a little bit from this david
graber's [ __ ] jobs which um i just i
finished um and i will say by way of um
sort of disclaimer uh i think the
numbers that i gave to you were i find
about 75 of what he uh of what he thinks
and writes
extraordinary and deep and just pointed
and accurate and there's a solid quarter
maybe it's less than that but that i
just completely disagree with so i will
just say um i
actually assigned his essay [ __ ]
jobs to my class which was the basis for
this book um and i think it is
insightful um i then encountered his
understanding of
adaptive evolution and it was
appallingly off yeah and it's clear even
in this book he doesn't he doesn't speak
about it directly but it's it's clear
that there's some just some
misunderstandings it's that's fine that
it's not that it's not relevant here i
just
especially when i bring up books and i
say i really recommend this like i
really recommend a lot of the thinking
here and especially the reveal that i'm
not going to go into here although i may
later of you know and when his
description of [ __ ] jobs i don't i
haven't i don't know where it is it's
different from what he calls [ __ ] jobs
what everyone knows is [ __ ] jobs where
you're doing real work that needs to be
done but you're not being paid well
enough and you're not being honored well
enough for the work right yeah [ __ ]
jobs are jobs that shouldn't exist at
all
and they tend to pay better they tend to
be white-collar middle-class or
upper-middle class or upper-class jobs
and
and know often no one including the
person doing them can figure out why
they exist at all but they're dependent
on them for a paycheck and healthcare
and all of us
um
that that all is not exactly what i want
to do here though i wanted to read just
a section from
near the end where is it
here we go
no
oh i forgot
i read this without book darts
tragic error okay here we go i've
actually marked up the book because i
was missing book there's just a page and
a half here okay
oh he's talking about um the turn of the
last century which is now that's not
actually how you would say it anymore
sort of the robber baron era in um
as the industrial revolution was was
ramping up and you know the so-called
capitalists were really taking over and
monopolizing sectors and um creating
beginning to create the heavily tiered
uh society that we have now
so from that point forward for the next
century or so labor organizing tended to
focus on factory workers partly simply
because they were the easiest to
organize which led to the situation we
have now where simply invoking the term
working class instantly draws up images
of men in overalls toiling on production
lines and it's common to hear otherwise
intelligent middle class intellectuals
suggest that with the decline of factory
work the working class and say britain
or america no longer exists as if it
were actually ingeniously constructed
androids that were driving their buses
trimming their hedges installing their
cables or changing their grandparents
bedpans
in fact there was never a time that most
workers worked in factories even in the
days of karl marx or charles dickens
working class neighborhoods housed far
more maids boot blocks dust men cooks
nurses cabbies school teachers
prostitutes caretakers and costumer
mongers i don't know what that is
then employees in coal mines textile
mills or iron foundries are these former
jobs productive in what sense and for
whom who produces a souffle it is
because of these ambiguities that such
issues are typically brushed aside when
people are arguing about value but doing
so blinds us to the reality that most
working-class labor
um
um
actually more much more resembles what
we are could typically think of as
women's work regardless of who's doing
it
being looking after people seeing to
their months and needs explaining
reassuring anticipating what the boss
wants or is thinking not to mention
caring for monitoring and maintaining
plants animals machines and other
objects then it involves hammering
carving hoisting or harvesting things
this blindness has consequences so this
is the point here
let me give an illustration in 2014
there was a transit strike when london's
mayor threatened to close perhaps 100
london underground ticket offices
leaving only machines
this sparked an online debate among
certain local marxists about whether the
workers threatened with redundancy had
[ __ ] jobs the logic put forward by
some being that either a job produced
value for capitalism which the
capitalists clearly clearly no longer
thought these jobs did or else it served
a social function that would be
necessary even if capitalism did not
exist which clearly these did not since
under full communism transport would be
free
needless to say i was drawn in asked to
respond i eventually referred my
interlocutors to a circular put out by
the strikers themselves called advice to
passengers using the future london
underground
it included lines like these so again
this is
this is the language of the people who
are striking
um
during the underground the london
underground closure in 2014 transit
strike
please ensure you are thoroughly
familiar with london underground's 11
lines and 270 stations before traveling
please ensure that there are no delays
in your journey or any accidents
emergencies incidents or evacuations
please do not be disabled or poor or new
to london please avoid being too young
or too old please do not be harassed or
assaulted while traveling please do not
lose your property or your children
please do not require assistance in any
way
graber continues it apparently never
having occurred to many advocates of
proletarian revolution to investigate
what it is that transit workers actually
did
this is
so important so if we can go back to
what we were talking about last week
comparing what is happening right now
which is an actual
honest grassroots
massive protest
in many places in canada that includes
real people who are saying enough i will
not i will not comply and this must stop
this is anti-constitutional and
anti-human
compare that to
the mostly middle-class lead
protests of the summer and fall of 2020.
which had these
fictitious fantasy-like views of what it
was that most people in the so-called
lower classes were living like and were
speaking on their behalf because what
they didn't believe that these people
could speak for themselves so here we
have right now people actually speaking
for themselves showing up and as i've
said before god i wish i could be there
and of course we can't because we can't
cross the border
but
showing up and every word that i am
hearing and i will actually be
hopefully publishing a few more words
from people who are actually there and
seeing it in natural selections this
week everything i'm hearing is how much
love there is
how much gratitude how much joy at being
able to interact with people again and
being able to see that people will stand
up
for their rights for their freedoms for
their humanity and what is the response
from the media that glorified an
actually violent set of protests that
reliably turned into riots at least here
in portland in 2020
they are
slandering these people and this
movement and claiming that this
is an insurrection
against democracy when it is exactly the
opposite
right and
it is not independent of what we were
just talking about because of course
it's not um these very properties the
media and the tech platforms are being
invited in fact strong-armed into
participating in this slandering and the
point is it doesn't matter if they're
right
yeah right because mal information is
what it is yep um
so i want to if possible uh pick up on
your theme here and point people to
something that is taking place in front
of our eyes where i think many people
traditional uh leftists
are finding themselves bizarrely
excluded
self-excluded from their own
uh revolution that they've been waiting
for
so i've been watching
chomsky who um i've been shaking my head
at for
many many months because he embraced
uh
the authoritarian nonsense not in the
strongest terms but my sense is here
you've got a guy
who
believes in
a collectivist viewpoint
hearing about a collective action
problem right the problem of vaccination
and embracing what seemed to him i'm
sure to be the scientifically
responsible collectivist
uh answer to this
and here he is
now on the opposite side of this organic
workers protest that is in fact quite
international across the entire
uh
west right you have these protests
against mandates and so you have icons
of the progressive
left who are now
opposite of the actual workers who are
revolting from what appears to be the
center right
and
i wanted to put this in context because
if you use
fascinating incidentally that uh the
so-called working class
should be identified as center right
when it has forever at least in the
united states been a you know the core
voter base of the democrats right now
my claim is that actually this does make
very simple sense if you just simply
track the parameters correctly right and
that what's happening is a lot of people
are using a heuristic right like well if
it's on the right it's bad you know
right um but what's really happening so
i've heard and you've heard and we've
all heard
hundreds
of
uh
people say you know left and right isn't
really such a useful distinction anymore
it's authoritarian versus libertarian
for example and no doubt there are other
schemes that matter but i don't think we
should give up on left and right i think
it still matters and if you map it
correctly here you'll see what's going
on so
my claim is going to be that what
defines the left is that it is biased in
the direction of attempting to make
progress
and what defines the right is that it is
resistant to attempts to make progress
on the basis that unintended
consequences
are an ever-present risk
and so the question is
why is it that the workers are on the
right now
in part what's happened is
good governance is something that the
left is favorable towards right this is
a sympathy i have good governance is an
important
fact of civilization functioning
the government
has been captured all of our governments
have been captured by economic forces
that exceed anything that our founders
could have envisioned right they
couldn't envision the internet or
economies of the scale or the kind of
interdependence and so the point is
those feedbacks
captured the government and put it in
the hands of powerful interests which
means that what could be good governance
is actually not good governance at all
it's governance being used against the
people by those who have captured it
right and we could go into why
those people would be against the public
but basically the point is look anything
that corporations want that's also good
for the people it's already done
right that means what's left for us to
fight over
are the things that would go one way if
they were in the interest of the people
and they would go the other way if they
were in the interest of the corporations
which is of course why they have
corrupted these systems was in order to
get things done that aren't good for the
people so it's part of why the
idea of a private public partnership
puts so much fear into our hearts
because we know that what is meant by
public there is not us it's the
government right and at the point that
the private public partnership gets
invoked it is the people who are out of
the loop and who are not benefiting
right it's um
it's private in public clothes
right it's it's the wolf in sheep's
clothing
a private public partnership is actually
private corporations with actually
supposedly public institutions which are
the government
right but in this case the public
institutions have been captured and so
it's really
the puppet masters
are
operating through both the private and
they are operating through the public
which they captured and i mean i think
that's just a different way of saying
the same thing the idea is that the
public government is supposed to exist
for the people not the other way around
and this is a point that's been made in
england with regard to the nhs and in
canada and the us as well that we are
not you know the idea that we need to do
things in order to protect for instance
you know the health system like no the
health system exists for us we don't
exist for it the government exists for
us we don't exist for it but at the
point the government decides that it has
its own agency it's you know it's it's
the it's the ai revolution that we've
been dreading in different clothing
right and it's no accident that it's
aligned with these interests that are uh
out of phase with what's good for the
public but in any case what i want to
get at is i think i said last week
that um that conservatives are always in
the business of defending the gains of
past liberals that is to say liberals
push towards progress you didn't say it
quite that strongly you said
you said maybe
well
i don't maybe i shouldn't even say
always because they're obviously weird
phases of history but say it again
without quite quite
that conservative conservatives defend
the past gains of liberals liberals push
towards progress some of that progress
is um
uh foolish to pursue because the
unintended consequences will be bad so
there's a tension between conservatism
resisting the unintended consequences
and liberalism pushing towards
solution-making that can be done and
what we have the fact that civilization
works at all is essentially by
definition
the result of progressives having
actually pushed towards progress that
was possible made lots of mistakes along
the way which presumably were largely
rolled back but we have a functional
system but in the 20th century
we got workers rights and children's
rights and women's rights and civil
rights and gay rights and on and on in
disabled rights and you know on and on
and on those are the ones that come to
mind right away all of these rights
that
i think in all of those cases
are actively being dismantled by some
branches of so-called liberalism and
it's the conservatives who are standing
up and saying wait no we keep those and
what they are arguing to keep is exactly
what the liberals were fighting for
anything from 10 to 100 years ago right
and even more than 100 years ago so i
would argue that the founders our
american founders were radicals right
they had a radical idea about good
governance and they inscribed it into
our founding documents and the point is
that you can see on the department of
homeland security's site that they do
not have that same opinion of those
founding documents right that they have
an antipathy for those founding
documents is some force rolling back the
gains of past liberals right and the
point is this is the natural role of
conservatives
is to oppose it right and the real
mystery here
is
okay
what are the progressives doing right
they should be pointing towards solving
new problems they should not be on the
side of unmaking the solutions to
problems that we've already solved but
what's happened is they have effectively
been bought off
that the corrupt governmental structure
has offered people who are feeling
shafted something and what they've
offered them is they've offered to
redistribute the well-being that exists
among
working people at various different
levels this is why the left is targeting
people
right they have been offered you can
savage those people and you can have
their stuff
right if you leave the rent seeking
elites alone yeah right so the left is
now a regressive force
right it is not a progressive force it
is not a conservative force it is a
regressive force and in the face of a
regressive left you would expect
conservatives to defend the gains of
past liberals which is what we're seeing
and the really interesting thing
is that
some people see this right glenn
greenwald sees it but noam chomsky
doesn't right and um that tells us
something which is that you can't use
these superficial labels
you have to
look deeper into the puzzle
um
wow maybe that's it
maybe maybe that's it i will say um
i'll say one more thing
found solace this week
last week there was a video going around
uh that maybe i'll find and link to um
in which the twisted sisters song uh
we're not gonna take it uh was put to a
bunch of uh of canadian footage of the
of the freedom convoy and it was it was
a little bit too well done it was very
it was very compelling and i've never i
never listened to twisted sister just
wasn't wasn't what i listened to and i
found myself listening this week to both
twisted sister and beethoven in roughly
equal measure and they were doing
different things for me
but i found at some points when i was um
just the most overwhelmed with the
tragedy thinking again about about mila
mila's story whom i talked about last
week
um and shush
um
here we go um
overwhelmed by that tragedy and by
seeing
seeing what was happening on the ground
in canada and
and also by how
how the people on the ground in canada
are being treated
um i
played pete opens ninth
blasted it myself both in the car and
then through earbuds walking along the
river on a very foggy morning
and then um
is pathetique sonata which is the last
piece that i played when i was a pianist
and so i found my fingers doing doing
their old routines while i was walking
along
and it seemed to me so odd
to be finding these two you know nearly
polar opposite
musical
they're not traditions they're just
they're instances these three pieces of
music really
twisted sisters we're not gonna take it
beethoven's ninth symphony and his uh
pathetique sonata um
all of which reveal to me at the moment
some of what we can be as humans and
also what we can be to one another and i
recommend finding some
deeply meaningful music and
and
playing it yeah i think actually i mean
i was never a twisted sister fan but um
i think uh we're not going to take it is
potentially going to go down in history
as one of the great pieces of
pre-made information pre-mail
information well it's clearly
mal-informative because we're not going
to take it and that's a fact but um
but you know it's not an okay fact but
the fact is they wrote that song before
anybody had invented the concept of mal
information last week
and so it was it's it's primal
information and uh if you're out there
twisted sister thank you
you're not gonna thank ludwig
um well ludwig is demonstrating the
opposite part of the puzzle he by not
saying anything in his orchestral works
except except for in the ninth right
exactly um
but with that exception is that the only
acceptor i think it might be
um
but in any case he most of the time was
not involved in misdis or mal
information at least professionally i
don't know what he said in his private
life no i feel like given given the
definitions of of mismal and
disinformation that have now been um so
so nicely framed for us i think the
emotional response that one has to um
to beethoven's both his his
his piano music and his orchestral
pieces uh could be construed themselves
as at least one of those things uh that
an emotional response maybe it doesn't
even take language to be engaging in mal
information you know what's gonna happen
yeah this is gonna be the next lgp no
lgbtqi
[Music]
plus phenomenon where as the department
of homeland security discovers modes of
human interaction that are not covered
by its definition of terrorism it's
going to add letters until everything is
covered and at that point i i guess we
can all uh rejoice in uh indefinite
detention that's going to be taking
place yes
all right um
maybe maybe that's where we'll stop for
for today um
we will stop for
as short a time as we can manage uh and
then come back with the q a uh again you
can ask questions
uh for the q a at
darkhorsesubmissions.com
if you
are an awesome web developer and are
interested in
in making yourself known to us we are
looking for one you can email
your
your information and what you've done to
darkhorsemoderator gmail.com our
moderator will be doing the first pass
on those
and um as always consider
joining us at our patreons reading
hunter gatherers guide
and all that all that jazz and uh and
and joining me on natural selections
yeah anything else well i think uh you
know go pre-bunk something
and also be good to the ones you love
eat good food and get outside be well
everyone
[Music]
you